I sort of remember I didn't do well here
here yeah the customers everybody is a
strong player but I think I can I can do
better so I'll look forward to the
challenge so because I like challenges
last year I tried hard but I didn't
think I finished some somewhere I do
slightly lower health although I was
fighting players are very strong you
know this the Grantchester there's no
there are no easy price here so you have
to fight every round but I think I'm as
likely to end at the bottom s at the top
things love the fiddler works out for
the best in Paris I mean in the
beginning it was topsy-turvy and then I
found my firm so I'm I think we'll get
the same sensation starting this
tournament I think I just got to play my
game take it one game at a time and
remove all kinds of pressure not to
think about the overall results so much
again we're playing 27 games here but at
the same time every game is it's crucial
three days of rapid it's slightly more
relaxed but the blitz is going to be
very tough anyway this wrap it in this
very specific sports
you never know before you start in which
formula for example I have played one
month in a row now sweet relaxing
classical but I did not have much
practicing repeating bit so I don't know
what kind of form ahem now I will say
the field is not only very strong but
also very young very difficult when you
are already over 42 to be you know to be
in it I mean of course you can try and
there is always a chance but since you
need a very reactive thinking and your
reflexes at some point you know I did
worse you know them when you are young
and a lot of energy takes a lot of
internship I mean you can see from the
tournament that just finished in Paris
that no lead is insurmountable
sustaining energy over the course of
five days will be
are very important I hope I can get
going immediately and have some fun